Il fait tout le temps
la gueule comme ça lui?
Ben, ouais,
ça va faire trois mois maintenant.
Euh, quelqu'un a une idée là?
J'ai.
Il pourrait se marier, ok?
Avec une meuf,
une bonne meuf.
Genre Ariane Massenet.
Mais dans un kebab,
pas dans un sandwich,
dans le restaurant.
Et à ce moment-là
entreraient pas la fenêtre,
des poulets.
Je t'arrête tout de suite,
ça veut rien dire, ok?
On s'en fout.
L'autre quand il va se réveiller demain,
il interprètera ce qu'il pourra.
Voilà, comme d'hab.
Et ...?
-Ouais?
Pourquoi pas un rêve de cul?
C'est facile à faire
et ça fait toujours plaisir.
Bon, moi j'ai peut-être un truc.
Mais alors attendez, parce que
si c'est encore pour me bâcher ...
Alors, vous me connaissez,
moi j'aime les trucs un peu dark...
Du coup, j'avais pensé à un rêve
sur la mort de son père.
Les cauchemars, les corbeaux,
tout le tintouin.
C'est bon, ça va.
On va faire
comme on fait d'habitude, hein?
On lit la liste de ce qu'il a vécu
dans la journée,
on s'en inspire et puis voilà.
-On va avoir un petit problème là,
parce que y'a pas grand-chose.
Le plus gros moment, c'est quand
il a maté les nichons de la caissière
et qu'il s'est dit
qu'elle était bonne.
Faut se faire une raison.
Son quotidien il est pas intéressant.
Son taff le saoule,
il a pas de meuf,
il a pas d'ami ...
-Pas de petit chat.
Pas de ... Quoi?
De petit chat.
C'est quoi le rapport?
-C'est hyper réconfortant un petit chat.
Comme un ami avec des poils.
C'est pas du tout ce que j'ai essayé d'amener.
J'essaye d'amener un fond...
Ce que t'essayes d'amener, surtout,
tu chies sur mon petit chat,
Parce que toi tu préfères avoir
une chauve-souris
Chauve-souris dégueulasse
avec une frange
qui écoute du Kyo,
Sortez les deux.
-D'où?
Vous sortez!
Putain mais le mec
est tendax de ouf quoi!
Ouais mais en même temps,
comment ça se fait
qu'on y arrivait vachement bien avant?
Je sais pas, ça fait longtemps,
je m'en souviens plus.
Mais c'est ça!
On se souvient plus.
C'est ça.
C'est ce que je viens de dire en fait.
Putain, je suis sûr
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'être ici.
Ah! Voilà!
Ah toi c'est vraiment ton truc,
c'est la mort, la mort,
la mort, la mort,
qu'est-ce que tu fais?
Non, non!
Et à ce moment-là,
la caissière du Monop'
on a qu'à l'appeler Annie,
elle prend la carte,
elle vient frotter la carte sur le nibard
qui commence à...
Il faut faire un truc sur son père.
laissez-moi deux minutes
pour vous expliquer.
Y'a de quoi faire
un truc super là dedans.
Ah oui? Et ben on va voir ça...
Un enterrement, oui c'est bien,
la maladie?
Oui, ça doit vous plaire,
Les weekends à l'hosto,
la mère qui chiale,
on va lui faire passer des nuits magnifiques à ce gosse!
Mais y'a pas que ça,
laissez-moi vous expliquer !
Je suis désolé,
j'avais oublié.
C'est rien.
Au risque d'être relou,
on fait quoi?
Parce que moi j'ai rien compris.
On l'écoute.
On l'écoute et on se remet au travail.